c'est une
belle journée pour mon sûr
année pour la vienne pour le département
parce que on monte par cette création du
11e villages d'enfants
l'implication du conseil général de la
vienne en matière de protection de
l'enfance qui est une compétence belle
passionnante difficile mais qui a toute
la dimension humaine et puis pour
monts-sur-guesnes c'est aussi une
merveilleuse journée parce que c'est un
projet qui devient concret un projet qui
va apporter de l'emploi de l'animation
du lien social et donc je suis très
heureux qu'avec le conseil municipal on
ait pu faire aboutir ce projet grâce au
conseil général les villages d'enfants
sont aujourd'hui une fondation était
très longtemps une association reconnue
d'utilité publique
notre vocation c'est de s'occuper
d'enfants ayant connu des difficultés
graves et qui de ce fait ont été par
décision de justice
retirait à la garde de leurs parents au
moins provisoirement
nous les regroupons toujours dans ce que
nous appelons des villages qui sont des
entités à taille humaine généralement de
huit pavillons du 6 places chacun ce qui
nous fait des entités de 48 qui peuvent
s'étendre à 50,52 et dans lesquels nous
cherchons à recréer autant que faire se
peut une ambiance familiale
un cadre dans lequel on associe les
enfants à la vie de chaque maison de
façon à leur donner quelque chose qui
soit le plus près possible de scorer et
et une vie familiale ordinaire et le but
étant de les remettre d'aplomb pour
autant que ce soit possible et tous nos
efforts vont dans ce sens là et je pense
qu'ils sont me semble t'il le plus
souvent couronnées de succès
nous offrons aujourd'hui le 11e village
de notre maison sur ce territoire et
vous venez d'enregistrer je crois les
paroles de monsieur raffarin qui mieux
que moi même ont pu dire tout le bien
qu'il pensait de ce type d'organisation
mon cher bruno je voudrais te remercier
parce que tu nous as donné aujourd'hui
une vraie fierté celle du coeur mecs
elle aussi de la raison parce que c'est
vrai le social est un investissement
le social c'est au fond le choix
d'avenir et c'est pour un territoire
rural dans ce si beau village de mots
c'est aussi la capacité de créer de
l'activité et de l'activité pourquoi
pour permettre à des jeunes enfants de
devenir des hommes est de faire en sorte
que il trouve ici les conditions de leur
épanouissement
il n'y a rien de plus beau et finalement
tout le monde se souviendra que mot
c'est le pays où il fait bon grandir